I was just doing what everyone else was doing. Partying,
vaping, drinking,
watching TV, eating fast food.
And I took hormonal birth control.
And to no one's surprise, I ran into a lot of health issues,
and I lost my period at 19.
Doctors said I was too. Too young to be concerned about my fertility,
and their only solution was birth control.
And then it dawned on me. I didn't need more pharmaceuticals.
I needed nature. I needed sunshine.
I needed real foods from the earth.
I needed to replenish all the minerals that I had depleted
when I just didn't know any better.
I needed to stop trying to chemically force my body into submission.
Artificially trying to replicate nature gets us nowhere.
And the reality of the female physiology is that it.
It thrives in a state of abundance.
And if we're living in a depleted or chronically stressed state,
that means that we're burning through minerals,
and we need to consciously rebuild a surplus.
Because having an abundance of resources
tells your body that it's safe to ovulate.
And this is called vitality.